hi
hi oh
all right this is so much fun uh camille
i want to start with you because when
you guys first dropped this it was in
the middle of everything nobody was
leaving the house nobody was seeing
anyone and then there had to have been a
point where you realized this show hit
like where were you when you were out in
the world and there were people where
you realized everything you guys hoped
worked
wow um i remember i was at my place at
home in paris with friends
um and i was like oh my gosh oh my gosh
people like the show guys and i i was
like on my instagram instagram it's like
graduation like my followers went crazy
and i was like okay is that a netflix
effect
so yeah i was so happy and grateful that
the show works and that people can have
some fun and joy and the feeling of
friendship
from their homes yeah
and uh lily um i mean aside from the
fans and the reaction to this i want to
know as a producer one of the things
that as much as people love the first
season there was calls for as there were
a lot of shows more diversity and i know
that this was something that you took
seriously
it was it was something that i think all
of the the creators on the show took
seriously and you know
the the amazing qualities of paris and
the fabric that make up the city
it's diverse paris is diverse in all
ways and a season two allows for us to
dive deeper into different areas of
paris to embrace the french culture more
the language the different types of
people you meet and we got to showcase
more of that in season two not only in
front of the camera but also behind the
camera with our crew and i think um i'm
really really proud of of our show and
our season as well as the other creators
and these women and our new characters
that we welcomed so it was really
important to all of us i remember lilly
as a producer i mean it's it's so fun
having your best friend be one of the
producers and i just remember how
excited she was and how much like she
talked to me about like oh my gosh these
people that we found that are like these
new parts of a romantic interest a
designer icon um a best friend like
there's diversity in all those things
and i just remember specifically how
excited she was whenever we talked about
that personally thank you
and uh with uh with cami and emily fans
you know what your fans are they are
like is something gonna happen and it
didn't quite in season one but like did
that shock you at all or did you sort of
get that same feeling and is there
anything that you can tease in season
two for the sleuths who love this show i
remember shooting that with comey
because it was like near the beginning
of when we started working together and
we were like
so we
is this gonna go some like where what is
the thought process here and i mean
wasn't it like andy that was like i
don't know
and we're like oh so we're supposed to
play it like we don't know but we but
but it was it was funny i mean honestly
i think that there's it was when i read
people commenting on it i was like oh
they registered the ambiguity of like
what we also felt so
honestly
honestly and emily in paris we're always
surprised when we read scripts so
i don't know
ashley is there anybody on that set that
has more fun than you do when you're
singing oh gosh well i will say
it's it's very much fun especially with
like the new cast members kevin and jyn
and getting to perform with them that
made a huge difference i will say quite
honestly it's a lot of work especially
the the songs where i had to dance and
there's a lot of preparation that goes
in for it but there's nothing like um
getting on a station performing in front
of your friends like like that first bts
song i can't believe we got a bts song
to be able to do so um it's it's
definitely a great time
and uh lily before i let you go um the
fashion on this show i mean it is it's a
character on this show uh do you have
things from season one and season two
that you begged to keep like how stacked
is your closet right now
um i definitely did beg to keep a lot of
items did not get to keep the items um
but you know i probably wouldn't have
worn them in quarantine anyway so uh
season two there were a lot more things
that i wanted i think we all want
different pieces from other characters
wardrobes like i was eyeballing kami's
wardrobe going wait no i love those
boots like i think we all would share if
we could
uh and uh kimmy before i i wrapped this
up fans even though emily and gabriel
shouldn't be together fans want them
together you sort of feel weird about
that as somebody in the show but also
obviously a fan of the show how do you
feel about that
well i think it's good that we have like
two teams kind of uh i think emily is a
character that tried to fix things she
knows that what she's doing is not quite
right but also she has truly true
feelings towards gabriel so it must be
hard for her to i
i wish i was not in her place so she
tries to do her best i mean it's a fun
it's fun show so yeah it's great that we
have two teams kind of
and that they're gonna fight for each
other it's fun
you